je trouve des spéciales chanteur se
trouve sur google maps qui est un jeu à
la promenade previews et loire c'est un
petit garçon qui vient d'emménager dans
une nouvelle maison on va mettre les
difficultés en médium moi la victime
ok alors les étudiants tu fais comment
ça marche donc le boogeyman à quatre
chemins pour aller dans la chambre
écoute bien le son qu'il fait selon la
direction par laquelle il arrive comme
ça tu seras dans quelle direction
regardez donc par exemple fait pas le
même bruit qu elle arrive par le couloir
ou par le placard le boogeyman apprendra
bien sûr est plus discret à chaque
nouvelle nuit au dos qui peut arriver
par la porte la fenêtre le dressing et
la ventilation qui avait fait cas
d'accord parfois nos piles sont vides et
on doit aller chercher nouvelle pile
sous le lit et je le fixais claude il en
profite pour se rapprocher donc il faut
prendre les piles aa après avoir fait
peur aux bouquets man revenir nuit c'est
parti auquel j'ai l'âge et la flash
l'aja flash lite d'accord dont clic
droit pour aller sous le lit et les
batteries sont prises automatiquement
dès qu'on entend créer une qu'il roulait
fois elle est la première à croquer ça
marche fatiha parents viennent
d'emménager
ils ont acheté une maison à bon prix
mais sont pas enseignées sur l'histoire
de la maison ce qui explique la présence
du bourguet man du bruit je suis au
taquet sur les bruits bon gars c'est
amuser quoi je peux pas lui mais là non
j'ai plus de piles merde
ok c'est bon jallet elle relève toi bien
oui je te vois [ __ ] mais sa salle
griffes des gueulards de parler je
republie montagut [ __ ] c'est après
faut-il intégrer un bébé mais j'ai aucun
respect tais toi t'es quoi remballe ta
caisse bata aérienne fidjienne qui
viennent mais il se paya une pile ya pas
de pile j'ai presque pu battre ils
achètent dans la merde [ __ ] c'est le
stress à 1 2 heure si ce n'est pas
complètement faux tenir mais jusqu'à 6
heures je pense comme femme night quitte
à copier autre affaire jusqu'au bout
ça c'est qu'on fera pas ce que j'ai fait
hu à la roche tam un [ __ ] de [ __ ]
qu'on puisse ma mère elle laisse la
porte ouverte et où avec un peu de
lumière est trop gentil et le monstre il
s'emballe et activia qui au salon est là
on attend j'ai paniqué oh oh là là haut
le fdp on l'a bien vu en plus horribles
akpa et keller 3 2 25
allez vas tu as beau losc ne connaît pas
nous chuchote pour autant si jamais un
bruit puisque c'est insupportable
totalement faux et puis il faut une paix
du pays le pil [ __ ]
ok alors là on est vraiment dans la
merde là je crois qu'on apprend on à peu
je peux vraiment l'allumé une demi
seconde la suite batterie à l'épaule
hausse s'il revient j'ai plus de
batterie
allez faut pas qu'il ait perdu 20
secondes sinon des baisers gagnent
publiait le pire aux yeux alors molesté
où on entend plus trop un grosse merde
ça dégage dégage mais attend et voilà
c'est gagné c'est gagner mais par contre
du coup on va décéder à l'école à on va
endormir sur nos tables toute la journée
nuit suivante y est [ __ ] enfin fans
arrêté après dix on est fort peut-être
parce que ce n'est pas la femme n'a pas
tr 10
je suis presque plus et lui passent plus
il arrive souvent et rapidement va
falloir être très attentif
ça dégage la main rouge t'as ptet
j'aimerais bien avoir une si d'écumé
samov la tâche là après ça c'était parce
que j'ai un côté psychopathe il est
réputé un book air vous savez quoi ça
fait penser obama duk sais pas si vous
avez vu jeu d'horreur le ce film
d'horreur dégageant à mains quoi mais
non mise à jour antivirus de merde par
autrui ne cherche pas mon nom mais font
tuer pas de faire ben oui mais mon gars
c'est bon je marche maman je pas marche
pas morges pas marié pas là parfait à
l'antivirus qui met la pression la bulle
est bon mais bon on est bon on est bons
avira tu auras pas notre combat tard
c'est tellement frustrant côté dans un
jeu qui est mise à jour d'un logiciel
que par retour une dose quoi à la main
qu'ils soient actifs et si on mettait un
peu de high school musical se détendre
l'ambiance
ok il appelle m'excuser écrit par le
beau ou khaimah genre fallu expliquer sa
démarche ne marche jamais ils
s'approchent de trop un petit coup de
flash lite a donc tu vas te voilà
c'était la chanson du boogeyman écrite
en deux secondes amical d'accord
grommerch appel dans la nuit le respect
se perd totalement ci aurait pas une
pile là tu as les pl se font rares dès
la deuxième il a pill c'est fini quoi
j'adore cette v2 en allemagne aussi un
des gars non mais attends mais attends
mais je viens de t'expliquer à l'aide
d'une chanson que ce que tu fais c'est
nul
bong a man who gaboury à l'oral au
revoir la main aux palois palois j'ai
senti une griffe là me couper un petit
cheveu ok troisième nuit on va commencer
par un petit saut pour se mettre bien
ces tensions le monstre à temps à se
concentrer à la main à la main
il est actuellement sain olala il nous a
fait trois agressions à l'espace de 15
secondes j'ai pas apprécié par conseille
vraiment il a ils tentent d'attaquer à
mort la manga il est même pas 2 à nous
attaquer plus deux fois que les deux
nuit d'avant réunis et le jour se lève
tôt la chambre de thomas ifile pour les
amuser avec quatrième nuit là je pense
que ça va se corser violemment quatrième
nuit
oh il est agressif là où il va cachin à
la bourre bien gardé boom regard des
gens pareils dans trois ou six mètres la
tension 1 et je compte vraiment lisbonne
1 2 3 échecs
cette voie là voyez olala vous avez vu
la cadence à laquelle il attaque c'est
abusé mon gars c'est grave sur moi pas
plus ça m'etonne la lâche pas bus + a
fini le plus de morts non filtrés
désinstaller d'antivirus de l'air double
retour windows c'est la fin ces lapins
double retour ils vont la banque tulle
et là il est dans la chambre
regardez dans la chambre voilà j'aime
relancer chez
toi tu vois ça servira ce pirate pour
servir à tian xi à teodorin aux [ __ ]
mais de quel sens je me mêle j'ai tenté
d'être viril
elle a remonté deux manches invisible
était pas mal mais voilà j'en suis fière
de cette vidéo sur mon gamin de toute
manière c'était tout dans la même chose
à vous qui à la longue c'est un petit
peu chiant mais on sait comme un musée
n'hésitez pas mes abdos ça vous a plu
dans le jeu et bien c'est infâme nataf
reddy's pour enfants c'est quand même
beaucoup plus simple que van natta de
près 10 mais moi je vous avoue que samba
entre nous moi j'ai pas trop de courage
du coup ça vous regarde et on se tourne
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo je
vous invite à vous portez bien ça ne
veut rien dire au revoir